peripheral neuropathy is a
common condition that occurs when
injury or disease damages your
peripheral nervous system originating in your
brain and spinal cord peripheral nerves
extend to your skin
muscle and tissue
your peripheral nervous system transmits
vital information between your body and
the brain in the form of electrical impulses
there are three types of
peripheral nerves motor nerves regulate
the movements of the
skeletal muscles in your body
sensory nerves transmit
sensations such as heat vibration
touch and pain to the brain
autonomic nerves regulate the
activities of the organs  and internal glands
each nerve is made up of several
interconnected cells called
neurons that transmit impulses at
the speed of light this
constant exchange allows your brain to respond
to the vital contribution of your body
however damage to your nerves prevents
this essential link  what r  results in
peripheral
neuropathy damage to a single nerve called mononeuropathy is
usually
caused by injury or
repeated stress an example of
mononeuropathy is carpal tunnel
syndrome repeated impact to the nerve
in your wrist can cause tingling
pain and weakness in your hand, arm, and
shoulder involvement of multiple nerves
called polyneuropathy is much more
common damage usually begins in the
nerves furthest from the
central nervous system and progresses
symmetrically polyneuropathy can be caused by
diabetes and other systemic diseases
infections or exposure to toxic substances
one or all of the three types of nerves
may be affected and the symptoms
are specific to each one the
sensory nerve damage typical of
diabetes can lead to numbness
in your hands and feet with a reduced ability
to detect  temperature
insensitivity to pain
or over sensitivity to it
polyneuropathy can also damage
your motor nerves which can lead to
muscle weakness
blinking
and pain
common signs of autonomic nerve damage
include heat intolerance
loss of bladder control and
gastrointestinal disturbances
breathing problems and heart rhythm problems
in general
peripheral neuropathy treatment focuses on
treating the underlying cause and
providing symptomatic relief
if you have a neuropathy you may receive
pain medication physical therapy to maintain
muscle strength or surgery to
relieve trapped or compressed nerves
if you have polyneuropathy your doctor
will treat the underlying disease  to
prevent further nerve damage
may recommend pain relievers to
ease your symptoms
if you have polyneuropathy with
sensory impairment your doctor may recommend
orthopedic shoes to prevent
foot injury